sentences in the case came after almost
three months of secret hearings at the
jordanian state security court
regarding the first criminal basemawada
the court has sentenced him to temporary
imprisonment for a period of 15 years
with regard to the second criminal
sharif hassan bin zayd
the court has sentenced him to temporary
imprisonment for a period of 15 years
the two men found guilty of plotting to
sole discord and ultimately undermined
the jordanian monarchy
bassim awadallah and asharif hasan bin
zayd
awadallah is a former minister who rose
to become the head of jordan's royal
courts
but he was not a popular figure among
many jordanians
who for long accused him of corruption
and financial embezzlement
award allah is also said to be very
close to saudi arabia's crown prince
mohammed bin salman and has been
described as being an advisor to the
saudi royal
his co-defendant sharif hassan bin zayd
is a member of jordan's hashemites
family
which has ruled the country for a
hundred years
the case against the two men began in
april when they were arrested by
security forces
the following day a video message from
prince hamza a former heir to the throne
and half-brother of the current king was
leaked to the media
he said he'd been placed under house
arrest
skeptics say the case against awadallah
and binsaid is a smokescreen
and that the government is using them as
scapegoats to tarnish prince hamza who
has been a scathing critic of how jordan
has been run in recent years
but the current king abdullah hussain
and his supporters say jordan's been the
target of a foreign plot by regional
powers
to destabilize the monarchy especially
after jordan's rejection of former u.s
president donald trump's deal of the
century
and the king's objection to gulf
countries normalizing of relations with
israel
of course the political ramifications of
this are many
the most important one it's a message to
the external
actors as well as the internal actors
who may have intentions to destabilize
jordan again
that the the state is very strong jordan
has been struggling economically for
several years a growing rate of
unemployment
and discontent has led to sporadic
protests
during which prince hamza's name was
sometimes chanted by demonstrators who
saw him as a symbol of reform and
although the prince has not been put on
trial
some believe monday's sentencing is a
clear message to government critics
it's obvious that they were trying to
convict even prince hamza so it's a
trial by absentees even for prince hamza
so i think this is the end game they
want hamza to be out of the picture
uh there was so many many jordanians for
instance
one times it to be the the regent but
now i think his chances are actually
slim
even next to zero this has arguably been
the most controversial case in jordan
for decades
and although a verdict has been issued
the defendants can still
appeal and the other court that of
public opinion
is still to give its verdict
al jazeera